ر مهما كان الانسان واجه من الم وتعب
واوجاع بده يتغلب عليها لانه هذا بالاخر
هذا قدرنا وهذه حياتنا وهذه الارض اللي
عايشين فيها فوين وين الروح فيش خيارات ير
ما في خيارات ولذلك الرضا الرضا
والتسليم والمقاومه المقاومه النفسيه
وال
تمام ايش الوضع صف ايش ثامن
ثامن ان شاء الله ربنا سبحانه وتعالى ببنا
ان تنت هالحرب هذه ونرجع
لجارنا ونرجع ونبدا الحياه من جديده
وتكملي المدرسه من جديد وتكملي مشوارك من
جديد
اي رغم هذه الظروف اللي انت فيها
والاعتماد على
الله الاول الاعتماد على الله ايوه
الاعتماد على الله هو اولا واخيرا وبعد
هيك زي ما قلنا الجهد اللي بسويه
الانسان خليكي قويه
ا الله
ار جدعه وضل جدعه ان شاء الله ك ضحكتها
داما اه ما شاء الله عليهها
جميله
ه